hello everyone
my name is erin gillard and i'll be
talking about the
parallel programming valves in c plus
plus
this being the very last uh session of
tech town i appreciate the fact that
you're still around
i know you're all in a hurry to get back
home
so thanks for staying with me
so a little bit about me
i work i started my my first
job in a small company called idea
where i was the only steeplesource
developer
or the only developer that used c plus
plus
and during that time quite a few years i
developed a developed taste for uh
community events mostly user groups
meetings um which were
actually the only way for me uh to meet
other
sql sus developers
so after a few years i went back to grad
school
uh obtained a phd from the technion
and institute of technology
and towards the end of my phd i
co-founded the high fossee plus plus
meetup group
which was the first sql plus meetup
group in israel
after graduate graduating i started
working at
yao research and around that time i
joined the organizing committee of the
core simplest conference
core c plus plus is the
other meetup group
in israel
so why do we care about parallel
programming
first and foremost it gives us
performance okay
we can utilize more compute resources
we can also use parallelism to hide
latencies introduced by io operations
and we can keep our uis more responsive
why is parallel programming hard well it
produces a non-deterministic execution
so subsequent and executions
might yield different results and it
also
introduces some issues such as data
races
and deadlocks and
and therefore having a structure in our
parallel programs can make things much
easier
so a programming model
provides some holistic structure
into our programs and that structure
allows us to use
some very useful abstraction
those abstractions allow the user
to better reason about the correctness
of the program
on one hand and on the other the library
which has a better idea about what the
user
is doing or trying to achieve
can provide useful features
at runtime since the
the library has a better idea about what
we are trying to do
and trying to achieve it can better
optimize the scheduling and the
execution
of our program
so both ends the compile time
correctness
and the runtime performance are crucial
in parallel programming
now because offers
a plethora of parallel programming
facilities
i've listed just a few here
and there are many more this
is neither a random or arbitrary
collection
nor a single api for parallel
programming
the facilities can be categorized into
three different
parallel programming models which are
introduced in this talk
the first programming model is what i
call a structure
which is a kind of a contradiction but
bear with me and the unstructured model
means that you
implement your own uh
parallelism mechanisms in your program
um using the lowest level mechanisms
such as thread mutex
and atomics and this model was
introduced in sql source 11.
the second model is task based which
uses
async promises in future introduced also
in
sql source 11. and lastly
the data parallelism which was
relies on the parallel algorithms
facilities that were introduced in c
plus 17.
those different models are not different
abstraction levels
they are a completely different way of
structuring your parallel program
so the outline of this talk
after this brief introduction is as
follows
first i'll describe three different
uh programming models then i'll compare
the three and finally i'll discuss
mixing and different models
this talk is about forest not about the
trees
namely i'm not going to deep dive into a
lot of
the details of the different apis but
rather try to
describe the model itself and how it can
be used
during this talk feel free to interrupt
me through the
slack channel or or
the webex chat and i'll try to
answer as we go or we can
[Music]
have a q a at the end too
so first model is the unstructured
parallelism model
this means we're using in this model
this ad hoc use of the parallelism
facilities
namely the structure is not determined
by the
language level api and facilities but
but rather by the particular use that
you
you find appropriate in your program
it relies on the lowest level
abstraction
and this means you have or you can
have at least a minimal overhead and
maximal hardware
utilization but on the other hand
it provides a minimal amount of safety
so you really need to know what you're
doing
otherwise you'll get into trouble
and this model i said was introduced in
sql source 11
and provided some of the central
features
of this language
version so the major components
of this model are at the lowest level
the memory model itself which means
which includes atomics and threadlocal
above that we have the threading and
synchronization classes such as spread
music
collisional variables and the newly
introduced in sql source 20
74 latch barrier and others
and above them we have convenience
repeals
such as the raii lock wrappers
call ones and the newly introduced j
threads
and and this forms the basic facilities
that we can
use for this model
some use cases that are
exclusive for this kind of program model
first is construct higher level
facilities
for instance we can create a thread loop
or a spin lock
second use case is concur implementing
concurrent data structure
either thread safe but log based
using mutexes or
even better log-free data structures
using the low-level atomics and we can
also use threads
for some long-running services in the
background
the missing part in this programming
model
is a safe shared state
so when we launch a few threads uh
the way for them to communicate is via
some
some sort of shared state um
either global or you know one that is
pointed by
various threats um
we can manage that state using atomics
but that is that or that can be a bit
too fine-grained and hard to get right
we can also use locks to
make existing standard containers
thread safe or for this kind of locking
can be
too coarse grained and and reduce the
the amount of parallelism we can obtain
in our
program so what when we need is
concurrent data structures
and this is being currently considered
uh
nothing ingredient but hopefully we'll
get
in the upcoming versions um
some facilities such as uh threads fqs
hash maps uh rcu data structures and so
on
um finger crossed
so the unstructured parallelism has a
few advantages and disadvantages
first of all we get maximal control
because
we are using the lowest level api
and we can possibly get the maximum
performance if we manage to get things
right
on the other hand it relies on a very
complicated memory model
and getting things correct is indeed
pretty hard and when you don't get
things right then
you experience fun stuff like data races
deadlocks
and non-deterministic results
so the thread level api itself has a few
shortcomings
a thread in general is an abstraction of
a processing
okay the thread gets
when it is launched uh an execution
entry point
um much like when you start a program
then you get a main that starts your
program
and the thread itself does not have any
functional semantics
further any synchronization among
different threads or
communication and scheduling they are
all interleaved
in the code that you're running with
that thread
okay so this is up to the programmer to
manage and it is interleaved within the
the parallel thread logic
what would have been nice is if we can
have some
higher level abstraction and some clever
runtime
that will allow us to do less work and
obviously have less bugs and potentially
gets better performance
since this has done
better and this
kind of solution is provided by
class-based
parallel model so tasks
are computations that are usually
limited in scope
and provide a single result or none
they can be functions lambda expressions
loop iterations and so on and ideally
have inputs and or output
but no side effects namely a as little
interaction with global state and the
good thing about tasks is that they
decouple functionality from execution
so you specify the task itself and
some runtime executes it
in an abstracted way
so one thread can be used to run many
tasks
on one hand and on the other hand one
task can
sometimes migrate between multiple
threads
and this is uh not something that the
model exposes
to the programmer
tasks are asynchronous namely the
creator
creates a task uh task it is
then executed somewhere sometime on some
uh other parallel or some
other compute resource and the creator
can proceed do other stuff until it
actually needs the result of that task
at which point it can wait and get that
get the result
and communication between the creator
and the task
is done by a channel that has two ends
the creator end of that channel is
called the future
which is basically a handle to the
outcome of the task
if one exists and on the
task and the the
the end of the channel is uh called a
promise
um and this is where the
the task sends the results to
so in c plus five tasks are launched
using
stood async okay
when you make a call to async it returns
future
and via that future you can obtain the
result
once the task is done
it's computation by calling
future git okay um
the the runtime
can assign the tasks that you create
through
async to different worker threads um
and this is something that can be a bit
surprising
for folks coming across the async at the
first time
on the first time um
and the somewhat surprising thing about
it is that the runtime here
the c plus runtime which has to be as
efficient as pro as possible
and can actually create and manage
thread pools
without the user having
a lot of control about it okay
so if you call async 1
you might have a thread running in the
background even after it returned
now the actual execution of the task is
determined by the first argument
provided to recall to async
and that can be and
there you have a few options the first
one is
a pass launch async
which means the task is going to be
going to be executed
on a new thread or better put as if
on a new thread async
does not necessarily launch a new thread
okay and one should not use async
to try to launch a new thread or get a
new thread
because it can use an existing thread
that's from an internally managed thread
pool
if one is available so it merely means
um the task is going to get to be
executed
on a separate thread from the one that
is uh
from the one that on which async was
called
the second option is launch deferred
which means that the task is going to be
executed
right before the result is needed on the
very same thread
that caused async so here
the task is not going to be executed
until you actually meet the result
and no other thread is involved in the
execution
if you do not call a future get then the
task itself will not be executed
so this is just deferring the execution
of the task
and lastly you can combine asic and
and deferred which is actually the
default
when no policy is specified and in this
case
the behavior is implementation defense
dependent
the runtime can decide whether it's more
appropriate to
run or execute the task on a separate
thread
or just defer the execution until the
result
is needed
so i said uh st the the results of a
task are uh delivered through a channel
that has to end
on the caller side we have the future
which provide access to the task result
and it's basically the pool end and on
the
on the task end we have a promise which
is the push end
and importantly you do not see the
promise itself
when you create a task using async and
as you saw you
specify say a lambda x version that
returns some value
and async stood async
moves that returned value into
the encapsulated promise so there is a
promise
within the channel but it's not exposed
to
the user that uses async and
features
if you do want to use tasks but you do
not want to use
async itself you can use a class
called package task which allows you to
wrap
some executable
using a task object
and from that task you can get the
future
which will again be the end of the
channel that delivers the result of the
task
and at this point we're still working on
the same
thread same color thread then we can
um create a new stud thread
and pass it the task instead of using
asic
some useful work and then again call the
future
gets and obtain the result so
this piece of code here is
similar to async but without the async
itself
execution so if you're not happy with
what
async provides say you want to
implement your own thread tool or so
you can use a package task
to to obtain at least part of the
functionality
and
so as c plus plus provide a task-based
programming model
if we consider some well-designed test
model
to be this beautiful horse then what
would the sequels plus
test model look like i say like half a
camel or so
it is missing a lot of things it misses
a
thread pool size or more generally
an execution context that the programmer
can control
it misses composition of tasks and
it misses cooperative scheduling and so
on
now the parallelism ts1 does provide
some extensions to futures
first it provides future.then
which allows you to chain continuations
to a certain task so you create a task
using async you get a future
and then you chain some other tasks
using uh future.then and that task
gets executed uh once the future
completes
and the result is ready it also provides
other facilities such as when all when
any
which allows you to chain tasks to a set
of tasks
unfortunately those experimental
features
are kind of on hold
due to the following reason we have
coverteen
and executors on the way so
covert teams introduced in sql software
are in short a mechanism that allows tab
and allows functions to be
paused and resumed from the same
location
or with the same state in which they
were paused
and once that those functions are closed
and you can do other things
and and this is a great feature to have
for a task-based model let's say
if some task is uh is being is executing
and it's now being stalled waiting for
say some
lengthy i o operation instead of
keeping uh the thread busy uh processor
busy
uh while it's stalled it can just
notify the scheduler i'm stuck
let someone else execute and resume my
execution when
when when i'm ready um and
that can be done using the covertly
mechanisms
so the task
crop where cooperatively
and gives up the execution context
moves aside let the scheduler execute
some other task and when it's ready it
is resumed from the exact same state
which is something core routines provide
so core teams provide one
nice building blocks for tasks executors
which have not been approved yet and
hopefully be
added to the language in peoplesoft 23
and provide a way to
define execution context so the
immediate example is some um
some thread tool okay you as a user you
can say
i have eight cores but i only want to
the the mall the
task-based model to use four of them
then you create a thread pool with four
and
only four cores and and let the
i think use that threadboom okay so
um
for a well-designed
test-based model and since
both those features are either newly
introduced or
not yet introduced there's no great
point in
extending async at this point of time
until other uh
the other mechanisms are available
so uh to wrap this up
uh let's compare phrase versus
tasks in general so first
threads the use cases that can be
appropriate for threads are background
services
long and complex parallel operations
um and when you have an equal amount of
pair thread work
okay because you want if you're using
multiple threads for some
and you want them to complete their work
roughly at the same time
so you get decent load balancing
on the other hand you want to use tasks
when you have many short
and independent operations not
necessarily doing the same thing
um when your those computations
are defined pretty much locally
using say lambda expressions
and that provides dynamic load balancing
so you can you can create a lot of them
and you can trust
the uh the task scheduler to make sure
that your
resources are utilized in a sensible way
as for stood threads and through the
sink
so studentsync provides
better resource utilization
when the when the task scheduler
is properly used it provides
a clean return value mechanism through
futures it provides exceptional safety
okay if a task throws then that
exception
is propagated to the future
um it provides time waiting you can
wait on a future with a timeout
unlike the split joints and it provides
multiple accesses to the future
unlike join which we can you can't
recall
multiple times threads on the other hand
mostly provided deterministic execution
context
which is a separate thread
okay so moving on to the third
programming model which is data
parallelism
so in this programming model
parallelism stems from the individual
computation associated with
every element in a collection okay
this means you have a collection or
in general a lot of data that is
mostly non-dependent um and the
algorithm
can divide the work among different
processors
and execute it this processing
environment
the general structure of parallel
algorithm
includes the following components
first of all the algorithm itself is
called from a sequential execution
context
okay you do not need to launch any
parallel
threads or something
then you define the execution policy
in a declarative way you just say the
desired
policy and the algorithm itself takes
care of the rest
and you provide the container with
processing you'd like to accelerate by
doing it in parallel
the parallel algorithms are a high level
abstraction
okay so you have a few customization
points
that you can use you have
no control over the amount of
parallelism
the scheduling of different threads
and how work is being distributed
on the other hand giving those
restrictions and abstractions
the library and the runtime can be very
efficient
um and when you use it properly you're
free from data races deadlocks and all
those
bad issues
parallel algorithms were introduced in c
plus
17. their adoption has been
slow in terms of component of support
they're currently only supported in gcc
and visual studio studio 2017
later editions and also
available as library implementations
provided by
intel or a coldplay
by their sql library
so how do we use parallel algorithms
um so first most
standard algorithms have a parallel
overload
and that's specified in the standard and
the first argument that you provide
to a parallel algorithm is the execution
policy
okay which i'll discuss in a minute
um and another difference between the
regular algorithms and the parallel ones
is the type of the iterators that you
provide
okay so in the sequential algorithms you
inputs and output iterators while in the
parallel variants you provide forward
iterators
which differ in in being
able to recall them or
store a forward iterator and re-access
it
even if it has moved
on which is important for
distributed data among different threads
this is a very important because if
you're
trying to move from a sequential
algorithm to a parallel one
and you just add an execution policy
then your code might not compile because
of the
type of iterators this is not
you know um this is not by accident it's
it's something
something sometimes something that you
have to really change your program for
as for the complexity requirements then
they are a bit more relaxed
on parallel algorithms because parallel
implementations might have to do more
work for the parallel
processing however
this a little bit of extra work allows
them to
process the data in parallel so the
overall
performance is expected to be better
the actual implementation of the
parallel algorithm
as the sequential algorithm
is not defined in this standard so
in theory you can use different kind of
algorithms and you can use
or sorry the
the the platform can use different
processing resources
such as a gpu if it finds it appropriate
so the first uh parallel processing
process
policy is called sequence policy
and what it means is that the parallel
algorithm is actually going to be
sequentially executed on the calling
thread
okay and so using the sequence policy
differs from the uh non-parallel
algorithms
in two ways first exceptions
invoke should terminate
this is the case with any parallel
algorithm and
and even if it
is executed sequentially and the second
difference
is again the use of forward iterators
now to specify a policy
you provide the algorithm with an object
which is an
instance of the policy type so
the instance of sequence policy is
called
execution sick um
and the idea is that
each object like that is has has a
different type
and this allows algorithms to be
overloaded
according to the different policies they
implement
okay and this means that the
policy specification is a compile-time
decision
okay even though you pass an object you
can't
make that a runtime decision because the
type of that
object is defined in compiling
the second policy is called parallel
policy
and the execution in this policy
is done by multiple threads as
determined
by the runtime um scheduler
um here
purse red processing is like the
sequence
policy namely each thread and
processes a single data element at every
given moment
okay it does not process
uh it does not interleave processing
of different data elements by
switching among them
the the order of elements that is being
processed
by each thread is not specified but
again
it is guaranteed that each element is
being processed
in the full by a single thread okay
now within each thread
if you execute your own code say by
using something like for each parallel
databases are possible if you access
some
external state that is not protected
okay as with any kind of um
parallel execution that is unsafe
however if you're not
accessing that kind of data
any accesses to the processed container
is guaranteed to be safe
the third policy is called unsec
parallel unsequenced and here
a few more restrictions are are provided
or
required and
so here they
a single thread might process multiple
data elements at the same time or at
least potentially do that
um and data
elements might be processed by multiple
threads
so this this poses some restrictions
on the code that you may write or may
provide
as the user for instance you may not use
any locks
okay and you cannot assume
that a thread executes a single
operation at any given time
those are some formal and requirements
that are
a bit difficult to understand but
what you need to have in mind here is
the following
using this policy or the restriction
imposed by those this policy allows
victorization
to be used okay so basically the goal of
those restrictions
is to make it possible for the
implementation to safely have a single
thread
process multiple elements at the same
time
using vector instruction
okay
and the last execution policy
is called unsequenced which is included
in c plus 20
and and according to this policy
an operation or execution is done
on a single thread again like the
sequential
execution however
operations can be interleaved namely a
single thread
can process multiple elements at the
same time
and this again allows us
or allows the implementation to use
vector instructions
to accelerate processing even if it's
done within the context of a single
thread
the standard also allows
vendor-specific policies to be provided
and those policies can use
different kinds of accelerators such as
the gpu fpga
and dedicated h basics
now one important thing to have in mind
is that parallel algorithms do not mean
parallel
containers okay the standard library
clearly separates containers from
algorithms and the fact that
algorithms can be parallel
does not mean that containers are made
straight
thread safe and the reason for that is
that
thread safe containers by default at
least
would violate the zero overhead
principle i mean
if you're not using uh parallelism in
your program
why would you have to pay the price for
being thread safe okay so
the uh parallel algorithms have to bear
in mind
in their implementation that they are
operating
on containers that are not spread safe
and so processing have to be um
have to to take that into consideration
so how is this or how can this be done
so for instance if uh if you're
processing
say a vector a regular vector which is
not thread safe in any way
can still be accessed by multiple
threads
as long as each thread accesses a
different element in that vector
okay this is safe according to the
simplest memory model
so processing data structures such as
vectors
is fairly easy on the other hand you
cannot change
or it's not easy to change the structure
of a container so replacing the
underlying
array within a vector can
cause a data races and even worse
updating dynamic data structures such as
sets
maps and so on that are basically trees
that are dynamically arranged according
to the data itself
that is stored within them
those data structures cannot be updated
in parallel because
they are not thread safe so the
algorithms
either cannot update them can
cannot update them or need to find
some way to make it safe
so one other thing to have in mind that
the fact that a
container is being processed by a
parallel algorithm
it does not make it again thread safe
during that processing namely if you
have two threads
one invokes some parallel algorithm
on a container and the other tries to
access that parallel that container
while it being it is being processed by
the parallel algorithm
then that can potentially create
a data race okay so safety is only
guaranteed within
the execution of the parallel algorithm
itself
okay moving on let's
compare the different models we
discussed so far
first in terms of the source of
parallelism
in the unstructured model it's custom it
depends on the
actual use case that
or the the problem that your program is
trying to solve
in the task based model parallelism
stems
from functional decomposition of
processing
whereas in the data parallel model
parallelism stems from the data itself
the state in a unstructured model
is basically shared among different
threads
potentially global in the task-based
model
the state is delivered by using the
promise to future a channel and in the
parallel model
the state is the container that is being
processed itself
the context in which we execute those
models
is again a costume uh
in the unstructured model uh in the task
based model
it would usually be this uh spawning
task will
further or can further spawn other tasks
and in the data parallel model
the parallel algorithm is invoked
from a sequential context
scheduling in the unstructured model is
again
custom it's up to the particular
implementation
in the task based model we have a
runtime scheduler
that uses a task queue and in the data
parallel model
we also have a scheduler that strives
to spread the processing
among all possible compute resources
and lastly the status of the different
models
so the unstructured model is well
established since
sql source 11. the task-based model
is again it also well established but is
will hopefully be redesigned and the
data parallel model
is being slowly adopted because um it is
uh
it has limited support
so the last thing i'd like to discuss is
missing mixing models
so first let's assume we have some
unstructured context
and we have a lot of reds that are
executing various operations
say by implementing a server
so within this context in which
most cores are used
we can use tasks if we want to hide
io latency
but we do not have compute resources
to invoke some parallel algorithm that
just doesn't make sense um
at least if we unless we can use some
additional resources
such as gpu
on the other hand if within our
unstructured
context we are only using a
few or or some of the compute resources
say we're using threads for some
background service and then we can
certainly invoke tasks and parallel
algorithms
however we do have to be careful with
shared state as with any parallel
processing
one thing to have in mind in this kind
of situation
um the runtime schedulers whether
task-based or parallel programming
parallel algorithms
are not aware of or may not be aware of
threads
created by the user okay if you create
multiple threads the runtime scheduler
might still try to create all possible
cores
and thus over oversubscribe your compute
resources
the next scenario is assuming we're
using
a task based program
which uses most of the course in its
execution
namely it creates a lot of tasks
and in this case within a certain task
it does not make sense to create
a thread to thread um or to use any
parallel algorithms we just don't have
enough compute resources
for that on the other hand if we're
using tasks
the just to hide io latency or
to uh to keep the ui responsive by
using a ui worker uh then we can use
parallel algorithms within the within a
task
um creating threads from within a task
does not really make sense um you can
instead spawn
new tasks and also
using synchronization mechanisms such as
mutexes
um is possible but doesn't really fit
the the model the task-based model
lastly if our power processing is based
on
parallel algorithms then within a
parallel algorithm
say your your own code
provided by a lambda there is no point
in spawning
async tasks or creating new threads
you can use synchronization mechanisms
again
mutex or some atomics
to access external state but you
have to be careful not to kill the the
parallelism
provided by the para algorithm
okay to summarize andrew tenenbaum once
said the nice thing about standard
is that there are so many of them to
choose from
and the same thing applies for sql space
parallel fatigue
facilities parallelism is hard
so in general prefer high-level models
parallel algorithms that provide a
simple
mental model they are slowly being
supported
but they have great potential with
future hardware
and new accelerators that based model
is underutilized due to its
unclear future
but future improvements are
certainly to be expected um and
in general the task based model is key
for
asynchronous programming so hopefully
we'll see
some significant improvements in the
future
thank you for bearing with me thus far
i'll have you to take questions
either online or through the task very
slack channel